I don't want to fit into a box I don't
want to be a genre you can get any
inspiration from anything to write a
song to make a shirt to like come up
with a video I'm so myself and I've
always been so strong-willed that I just
be like I don't care I'm gonna do what I
want to do and like that's that need
motivation watch it offended believe
nation
she's Billy Eilish and here's my take on
her top ten rules to success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one do what you love think about singing
was that singing was never like I want
to try this he was already there it's
never been a question never been like a
thought and I've been singing since I
was born and all the time and hearing
people be like oh you like to sing was
really weird for me cuz I didn't know
people didn't like to sing I guess that
kind of awesome into whatever I am now
remember - don't be fit in a box I don't
have a sound and I feel like the people
who think I do have a sound are wrong I
feel like if you think I have a sound
like don't listen anymore cuz I don't I
don't want to fit into a box I don't
want to be a genre I think like I say
all the time like if it's a good song
it's a good song it doesn't matter where
it fits and if you like it you like it
rule number three find inspiration
everywhere all of the influences come
out everywhere I mean you get influences
from everything you get inspiration from
right I could literally like look at
this bag and be like look at how the
zipper is and look at how like the
shapes go like this and how the colors
change and how the belt buckles like
this like you know the way that the belt
buckles are like the way that it clips
or the way that it tugs and whatever any
you can get any inspiration from
anything to write a song to make a shirt
to like come up with a video you know
like it just comes over
comes out of everything you can look at
you know you can get creative and
inspired by anything really so I think
I'm definitely always doing that I'd say
and like letting it out and in song
writing and singing and the way that I
perform and the way that I you know act
and stuff like that rule number four be
authentic the fact that my parents were
so artistic and I was like surrounded by
creativity my whole life was definitely
the reason I'm
I am Who I am but I feel like even if I
had been raised to be whatever other
people are raised up s I'm so myself and
I've always been so strong-willed that
I'd just be like I don't care I'm gonna
do what I want to do and like that's
that I'm still like that even with the
supportive family that I have I'm still
like anything you say I'm just gonna do
what I want
also if you want to learn from other
successful women entrepreneurs check out
my 2:54 girlboss series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
become so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed when I
was bartending I was fully bartending
like I wasn't talking to myself about oh
my god I should be dancing right now or
I should be working on my coaching
practice rule number five work for it do
you have friends that went to Normal
School as well all my friends are no
what do they think about what's happened
to you since like how are they reacting
and how they dealing with their friend
who's now traveling the world playing
first of all well I think what a lot of
people not just my friends and people I
know think is that they don't really
realize that it's my job you know it's
just because I'm 16 and you know it's
not like a job at a desk in some office
somewhere it's still my job and I still
have to work for it because they just
don't they just don't put those together
it's like oh this is just some fun thing
that has no does you don't have to work
at all and you just have to like
bro rule number six be driven you know
you really should not just perform off
the audience's energy your own energy
but it's hard to always do that you know
you're gonna feed off their energy no
matter what it is it's really the reason
I can do it almost like it's the reward
I get you know touring and being an
artist is really really hard and it's a
lot of work so you know the only thing
makes it worth it is performing for the
people that support you a lot of what
you ate
rule number seven never stop evolving
here's the thing like everybody changes
no matter what you are so it's like if
somebody's like oh my god she's changing
for fame no [ __ ] oh yeah I'm changing
because I was fifteen as I'm alive when
I'm 16 now
yeah and in a year I'll be 17 in a year
I'll be 18 do you know what I mean like
the difference between a 15 year old and
an 18 year old that's insane
so it's like I never want to I never
want to stay the same ever not ever so
it's like you know you have a goal I'm
like no I don't want a goal cuz if I get
that goal then I'm never gonna do
anything again yeah so you can have more
than one goal actually that's yeah
you're totally legit so I don't want to
be like stuck on something I'm changing
all the time my style is completely
different than it was it's gonna keep
getting different I don't ever want to
have a sound I don't ever want to be in
a John or like you don't let don't
remember eight be focused and present
when I perform it's just like I'm just
thinking about it like nothing except
exactly what I'm about to do
[Music]
if you think about anything else it'll
it'll really throw you off I've had
shows where all I could think about was
you know something horrible and it just
ruins the show it ruins you at ruins
your mental state and it just is not
good so you just gotta shut up in your
brain just do really not remember your
why I want to learn that it's all worth
it because it's tiring as heck and it is
worth it and I have to remember that
because being with like fans and doing
shows is way more important than being
tired is it worth it yes the show's make
it worth it
the shows and the supporters that is
something you have to remember when it
it doesn't feel worth it because a lot
of it doesn't feel worth it but then you
get to the points that do make it worth
it and it's like then it all sort of
makes sense and it kind of clicks in
your head and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
listen to your haters when people hate
on you listen to them because they're
probably right I mean I think hey it's
funny dude like when I
I love hate like I read hate comments
more than I would like read nice
comments because that's like wow they're
creative you know what I mean they're
really creative with what they say and
most of the that they say sorry mom
most of the stuff that they say I agree
with 100% so like listen your haters
they're right now I've got a special
bonus clip from Billy on how to not be
sad that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions time to go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
what's one thing that you have learned
from your haters number two where do you
need to do a better job of being present
and focused and number three what can
you take inspiration from in your
environment right now don't be so sad
it's such a waste of time ah I didn't I
didn't live up to that then and I still
haven't lived up to that so it's good
advice though
it is a waste of time dude ah it's
ruined so many things that could have
been amazing because I was sad
dumb but whatever
if you want to learn how to make it as a
musician check out their video link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I want to tell you the
most important piece of information that
applies not only to your musical career
but your entire life and I've seen it
work and I've seen it not work